where are you from in wales just outside
hannah clark celebrates her 94th
birthday tomorrow
the vaccine means she can look forward
to a much more hopeful year
ahead hannah have you been afraid
not only for yourself but for the safety
of your friends
well yes i have wonder where they're
going what they're doing
and hope they don't go anywhere where it
is
and that's yet touchwood i've been quite
unlucky
nobody that i know has had it
but it's terrible stories of people that
have had it
and the vaccine will change all of that
well i hope they do
well if it only changes two bits of it
it's two bits less isn't it and if a
vaccine keeps it out
good for all of us
it's been really difficult for the
residents of the meadows residential
care home
no hugs no cuddles from loved ones
it's right that they've said that care
homes will be
one of the priority groups and i think
that is right because
of the number and the thousands of
people who have
unfortunately died in care homes
up and down the country uh we're lucky
we haven't had any death in here
we never had the virus in here but it is
right that they should be vaccinated
the government wants to protect the most
vulnerable from covert 19
before anyone else but getting the
pfizer beyond tech vaccine into care
homes
is going to be almost impossible
in the vaccination roland's first phase
care home residents
and their carers are the top priority
next on the list are people aged 80 and
over and front line health and social
care workers
some nhs workers will have higher
priority than others
depending on their roles the list is
then prioritized
according to age and clinical
vulnerability
this is the wish list but delivering it
will pose problems for the government
and today they said that over 80s and
care home staff
may be first with care home residents
having to wait
here's why the vaccine needs to be
stored
at a minimum of minus 70 degrees celsius
over 50 hospital sites in england have
been identified
as hubs the vaccine can be only
transported
four times because of the mhra license
and three moves are needed
to get it to storage hubs in britain so
the last move
needs to happen just before the vaccine
is administered
the vaccine comes in batches of 975
which means potential waste
if care homes which typically have
dozens of residents
receive one batch each we know the nhs
will take delivery of 800 000 vials of
the vaccine in the coming days
that's enough for 400 000 people
and the mhra is still considering two
other vaccines
one by modena and the other from oxford
astrazeneca
which do not require extreme cold
storage temperatures
making distribution easier
some medical staff are being readied to
receive the vaccine
this means that staff working in the
highest risk areas
along with us those staff who are
themselves deemed to be at high risk
for example shielding and bain staff
will be the first to receive the vaccine
those in critical care roles are likely
to be fast
i'm over 60 so therefore i was an age
group who has had less contact with
patients who've had
covered 19 than some of my colleagues
and so what it means is i can go
back to doing my job in a more normal
way because i will be to some extent not
completely but to some extent protected
it's unlikely the vaccine will reach the
meadows care home
soon the residents here will have to
wait
until a way is found gilbert what does a
vaccine mean for you
well i hope it will extend my life a
little more
extend my life ashish joshi
sky news